lorsque vous recevez la médaille bleu
blanc rouge de meilleure apprenti de
France sous les ordres du Sénat vous
êtes toujours en situation irrégulière
nous accueillons notre invité du Samira
20h ce soir Christina Dimitri bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
alors à un seul les Roms symbolisent la
droitisation du gouvernement en effet
depuis le discours de Grenoble de
Nicolas Sarkozy le 30 juillet 2010 le
débat autour de la communauté ne faiblit
pas et les polémiques se succèdent tout
ça ferait presque oublié ce qui
réussissent à s'intégrer alors que vous
viviez sans papier depuis votre arrivée
en France en 2005 vous venez Cristina de
décrocher le prix de la meilleure
apprenti de France
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout un symbole
de nous raconterez votre histoire à 20h
[Musique]
Christina rebonsoir
vous êtes né le 4 décembre 1993 à
Tournoux Séverine oui un petit village
au sud-ouest de la Roumanie votre père
Adrian et votre mère ribana travaille
d'arrache-pied dans les champs et dans
les serres de la région pour vous
scolariser et finalement il trouve les
sous pour vous inscrire à l'école du
village pour retrouver les sous ils ont
mis ils ont même allé
en Italie pour travailler pour
oui parce que votre père avait souffert
de pas être scolarisé et il a voulu
absolument que ses enfants vous et votre
frère soyez scolarisés vous commencez en
CM1 alors vous aimez l'école j'ai
toujours aimé ma
curiosité d'apprendre des choses c'est
ma fille
apprendre
c'était pourquoi l'école il est la plus
importante
alors vous rattrapez votre retard vous
rejoignez les meilleurs élèves de votre
école et vous passez sans problème en
CM2 puis ensuite en sixième en cinquième
etc enfin faites une scolarité tout à
fait normale malgré le fait que vous
ayez commencé plus tard que les autres
oui j'ai commencé à 7 ans
mais alors que vous avancez
tranquillement vers l'adolescence votre
petit frère cosmine souffre d'une
malformation de la main droite et ne
parvient pas à suivre le même parcours
que vous c'est là qu'un cousin de votre
père vous conseille d'amener l'enfant à
Nantes en France donc pour le faire
opérer
il nous a dit que les médecins d'ici
sont les meilleurs donc en août 2005 les
bagages sont prêts la maison est fermée
à double tour et la famille dimitrou
embarque dans un minibus déglingué qui
dépasse pas les 100 km/h faudra quand
même une semaine pour faire les 2500 km
qui sépare votre village de Nantes quand
même
le soir comme vous avez pas d'argent
tout le monde dort dans le minibus mon
père et ma mère ils avaient pas prévu la
nourriture pour
ils avaient prévu la nourriture pour 3
ou 4 jours en fait on a partagé la
nourriture qu'on était
un bon souvenir de ce voyage hein
[Musique]
naturelle était très belle et j'ai passé
des mots des bons moments avec mes
parents et les autres aussi
catastrophique parce que le chauffeur à
peine arrivé vous débarque en pleine
ville vous laisse au milieu et repart en
Roumanie c'était pas facile parce que
qu'on connaissait personne cousin
et on n'avait pas son numéro et c'était
un peu retrouver le cousin de votre père
c'est difficile parce que dans un
village en Roumanie bon tout le monde se
connaît mais à Nantes il y a 300 000
habitants
vous vous posez la nuit dans un parc
vous savez pas où habitait votre père
monte la garde parce qu'il a peur que
vous soyez agressé par des par des
clochards et heureusement trois jours
après donc vous retrouvez la trace du
cousin qui vous héberge dans un
mobil-home qui est dans un campement
pour les Roms les Tziganes aménagés par
la mairie de Nantes oui on avait tous
les conditions
votre père achète une caravane qu'il
paye 150 euros qui est obligé
d'emprunter évidemment à son cousin et
là vous vous installez loin du parc
aménagé par la par la mairie vous êtes
dans un petit bois
derrière la ligne de métro et là vous
vous retrouvez à vivre sans eau sans
électricité vous vous éclairez à la
bougie et pour avoir de l'eau bah il
faut marcher un quart d'heure porter les
gros bidons sur le dos etc ça c'est
compliqué là
parce qu'on remanie on avait quand même
d'eau d'électricité
c'était très compliqué qu'on est arrivé
alors en plus pour vous laver bon bah il
y a pas d'autre solution que de faire
chauffer de l'eau sur le sur le gaz
alors vous mettez dans une bassine et
votre mère vous arrose qui fait des
petits gobelets d'eau chaude
alors pour gagner un peu d'argent votre
père ramasse des fils électriques à la
déchetterie et il va les revendre au
Ferrailleur mon père il a été obligé
pour
le ressortir mon père il pouvait pas
travailler c'était à cause de ça il a
été obligé d'aller
déchetterie dorée récupérer mais il faut
opérer votre frère alors au bout de
quelques mois après avoir remboursé les
dettes qu'il avait au prix de son cousin
votre père parvient à s'acheter une
voiture il peut faire plus de trajet
entre la déchetterie et les ferrailleurs
votre situation commence un petit peu à
s'améliorer à ce moment-là
parce que c'était plus facile aussi
d'aller chercher de l'eau et la voiture
oui dans la voiture malheureusement un
soir alors que vous êtes invité chez
votre cousin dans un campement aménagé
par la mairie dans son mobil-home la
police débarque et arrête votre père et
son cousin le matin
la police est arrivée pour
faire un contrôle en fait et tout ce
qu'ils avaient pas les papiers et qu'il
dépassait les trois mois parce qu'il y a
à l'époque c'était comme ça en fait pour
Marseille a été très difficile parce que
si mon pays il était exclusé sur la Rome
Roumanie mon frère il était pas encore
soigné on avait peur que mon Frédéric
soit passionné
c'est un centre de rétention mais pour
vous c'est comme une prison donc vous
allez avec votre mère avec votre frère
le voir dans cette endroit ça dure trois
semaines
les autorités françaises évidemment
parlent de le renvoyer en Roumanie toute
la famille évidemment a peur et le salut
viendra d'un curé le père sauvé qu'un
nombre assez prédestiné qui convainc le
juge de vous laisser en France le temps
que votre frère soit opéré oui c'est
vrai en fait
il est bien
merci beaucoup Christophe pour tout ce
que tu as fait pour nous
alors
grâce à lui votre père commence à
travailler dans l'agriculture ce qui est
son métier en fait son vrai métier c'est
ce qu'ils faisaient en Roumanie et votre
petit frère obtient la couverture
médicale universelle donc là ça commence
à aller mieux vous vous installez dans
le camp où vous étiez au début et là
vous êtes tous pris en charge par une
association qui s'appelle une famille un
toit et qui vous aide à retrouver vous
le chemin de l'école voilà ça c'est déjà
de nouveau scolarisé cette fois en
France alors au bout de quatre mois de
classe préparatoires où vous côtoyez des
serres des Russes des Croates des
Marocains des Algériens vous êtes
autorisé à vous inscrire en quatrième
ça doit être dur pour vous quand même en
fait je suis restée à la maison
malheureusement sont allés à l'école et
j'ai fait que quatre mois de préparation
et ça a été dur par parce que c'était
moi j'ai pas je savais pas encore parler
le français je comprenais pas tout et ça
ça m'a mondé beaucoup travaillé
vous décrochez haut la main votre
diplôme de français là vous décidez de
vous inscrire au cap du pressing du
prêt-à-porter et de la vente oui la
première année en fait c'était un
cap de faire tous 6 heures de vente 6
heures de pressing qui est 6h d'eau prêt
à porter le pressing la connaissance et
le tri des tissus l'entretien le lavage
le repassage le fonctionnement des
machines de nettoyage en quelques mois
votre volontarisme fait l'unanimité et
les profs décident de vous inscrire au
concours du meilleur apprenti
oui et là vous gagnez le concours au
niveau
départemental
régional et national c'est bien
alors lorsque vous recevez la médaille
bleu blanc rouge de meilleur apprentis
de France sous les ordres du Sénat vous
êtes toujours en situation irrégulière
et là la presse titre une jeune Rome
sans papier meilleure apprenti de France
et le lendemain vous aviez votre carte
de séjour
ma carte de séjour parce que là j'ai
pouvais réaliser mes rêves
qu'il travaille malgré lui
s'intégrer en français tout ça ils ont
pas la carte de séjour pas encore
ma femme moi j'étais à ça quand même de
gagner moi un meilleur apprenti parce
que j'étais un même catégorie je suis
arrivé deuxième elle m'a battu
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu